nier
[Applaudissements]
oui on voit que c'est les vacances parce
que quand c'est les vacances
il ya un public de vacances donc quand
tu es touche pas à bon il faut un convoi
qui l'énergie sexuelle devienne une
énergie créative et ben ça c'est pas
vérifiées alors j'ai tenu 86 jours non
deux ont un poids de 2 ans j'avais
autant sans coucher mais à quel âge ses
mac lesggy kate avec nous alors il va se
passer quoi dont hugues gall m6 famille
ni à l'ordre games is family on va voir
les reportages façon et de m6 commençait
bien faire et surtout en plateau avec
gaël on va faire des expériences adore
on va montrer comment on peut faire
tenir par exemple en effet une
l'expérience on a commencé à tourner
comment faire tenir un trombone à la
surface de l'eau sont qui coule et
grands le faire couler sans y toucher
ces chants mézin oui champion du monde 2
min ping pong des mini ping pong
vraiment wawrinka jeudi éclaté
gasquet je vais éclater gaël monfils qui
m'a approché faut pas taper là bas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
au toucher
[Musique]
mais il faut que tu vas t'entraîner tu
vas t'on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
twitter c'est pas voilà donc réunis en
direct pour commenter ce match tant
attendu mais il est nul
nelson je suis heureux de vous avoir à
mes côtés pour commenter donc cette
triple 5 à 0 5 à 0
les dents jusqu'à 10 effectivement faut
favoriser le passage à 0 en une minute
tous les records sont battus le quoi
enfin le premier point rencontrés par
ses réelles
9 6 on constatera quand même que les
points de dominique sont en train de
construire six si j'ose dire alors que
les points de syrie sont souvent sur des
fautes directes mais
[Applaudissements]
donc l'élection de miss france et le 14
décembre prochain au dôme de marseille
va vous dévoiler les 30 candidates à
l'or il ya miss tahiti miss tahiti alors
on va parce que on va voir miss tahiti
souple et sema paris bousquet appel à 22
ans elle fait un mètre 80 alors qu'ils
me sur l émission merci
non non les mecs vous avez vu ce qu'on
fait là c'est quand même fort et ma
voiture non mais c'est la france c'est
horrible on est là oui non oui non mais
t'as vu ta tatouage et de maquillage
[Applaudissements]
je vous dis faire quand vous étiez
petits bouts c'était quoi vous pourrez
vous voulez faire toi comme métier
l'imitateur aux newsletters
mais tata les rabbanim fait le masi a
voulu que je fasse une chance à ne plus
aimer m je trouvais tu veux là nous
excuse moi mais rien aux quelques
instants c'est un bordel
[Musique]
alors si vous n'avez pas tes artistes à
succès j'aurai à prêter n'est parce que
j'ai très vite compris pourquoi
mais nenê oui parce que j'ai très vite
compris que le no look ne veut pas non
mais pas pour n'ai pas faim je m'en fous
parce que pour l'amour quand tu sens
l'autre c'est physique qui est un truc
qui se passe et tu sais si ça va aller
par exemple ma me sens pas bon mais je
dis vous par exemple tout de suite là
oui d'accord mais là c'est physique là
la cua
oh la la
l'imitation parce que vous vous limitez
très bien moi je peux faire céline et
tout faire des bonds journée j'étais
ralink kas est donc le champ taxant les
frais ça va pas péter les tympans
[Rires]
je replante tk7 biais je sais que je
vais écouter psoe selon un diamant brut
que je vais écouter piqué pour faire de
toi comme star brésilienne puisque tu as
couché à ça